what's up melinda i wanted to ask how to
mentally prepare our family for my
husband's upcoming deployment
is this his first one a second second
one okay so tell me about the first one
so the first one um it was a nine-day
notice but we kind of ripped the
band-aid early on
yeah how long was it gone for about
seven and a half months nine days and
seven and a half months
yeah whoa that is slap it up flip it
reverse it dude that's
quick so then so y'all got through it i
guess right
we did we did we did get through it we
um
we came out of our marriage a lot
stronger okay our kids at the time
um but we're about one and three-ish
oh my god so they i mean
they didn't know any better so it was
kind of like thinking back now
it was kind of easy um now fast forward
they're five and seven so now it's um
you know they're more attached so that's
why i'm
kind of like wanting to seek more advice
on how to go around at this go around
yeah for sure okay so you got a five and
a seven year old how long have y'all
been married
uh we've been married for going on seven
and together for 11. okay uh dude
island's in the stream that's what y'all
are dude that's awesome
seven and eleven very cool and then hey
what did you learn last time that helped
improve your marriage
communication what does that mean
um that means if i'm having a hard time
i kind of need him to be my ear okay you
know
through the good and the bad um
and on his side he kind of like puts
like
i don't know he there's a boundary like
he can tell me about all the work stuff
but at the same time i can't understand
all that he's going through right yeah
and that
that's one of the most common things i
hear from
couples and especially from the person
who's deployed
is how do i stay present in my
relationship at home
and not let them know what's actually
going on here
and not let them know hey we were you
know drove over an iud today
and not fill in the blank right and be
fully present there
but all yeah it just becomes really
tricky and how do you
as mom get to have a bad day when you
know he's over there
doing god knows what right so it's that
mess man so what are some tricks you
guys learned
to communicate better
um i guess
just uh making time you know when the
kids are asleep or
you know being on opposite schedules
making that
time whether it's super early for him or
it's super late for me like making time
that we can actually
you know just have a conversation
whether it's like just
can just talk like we would regularly
but outside of all
the background like our situation or
whatnot um
yeah i think that would be so when when
does he leave
uh sometime this summer okay so you've
got a few months to plan for this
are you gonna have time to do a vacation
together do something fun together or is
it gonna be work work work and then
we're out of here
we've been taking vacations um so the
the
this deployment we've known it for about
nine months ahead of time
that's like good and bad we're able to
plan it better but it's bad in the sense
it's kind of like dragging and
getting dreadful yeah and it keeps going
and going
so what do your kids think about this
we haven't told them yet what
yeah we don't melinda
why why we we will we just don't want to
drag it for them either
okay so we were thinking like two three
months before he actually does
you know deploy to go ahead and let them
know that this is what's gonna be
happening
okay your heart and his heart are in the
right place
and it is but it's out in the yard okay
so you want to give them time to
digest this internalize this and norm
this
okay okay and there's several ways
you guys can do this as a couple um
and there's some really cool ways y'all
can do this as a couple here's the thing
they're gonna miss their dad you're
gonna miss their your husband
y'all's family unit is gonna have a big
gaping hole in it
right and the band-aid thing can kind of
work for grown-ups
because you guys have multiple frames of
references this is their world
and giving them some heads up in ways
that they can see and feel and
understand
really makes a difference it turns it
into a hard time
it it switches it from it being a hard
time to trauma
okay okay dad disappearing
after a nine day notice or a two-week
notice is
a like that's a an explosion in a
child's mind
dad going through some things and we
know this is gonna happen and here's the
day and here's when this happens
that is something they can digest in
little pieces okay so here's a couple of
things that i would recommend you all
do that can be a lot of fun it'll be
hard but it'll be a lot of fun
okay okay um first thing is
is i would get on amazon or i would have
your husband check around
base there's going to be some children's
literature
about mom or dad deploying
and what we want to do is we want to not
leave what deployment looks like to your
kids imagination we want to paint that
in as clear a picture as possible
reading stories to kids where they see
themselves they see daddy they see mommy
is a beautiful way to let the kids
digest it in a way that they can you
know through a cartoon right
so i'd get online and see if you can buy
some books and then just make
reading at night a part of your rhythm
moving forward
do you all do that anyway we do okay
awesome so this is just some new
literature you can
you can introduce this weekend you can
get on amazon today and order it and
they'll be here by the weekend and you
can start that
the second thing is is begin and
hopefully this sudden sound cheesy but i
want this to become part of your rhythm
so that when they go it's a part of
their rhythm
begin a weekly hey we're gonna make a
thing for dad
you and the kids and have your husband
do a weekly
i'm gonna make something for the kids
and then y'all can exchange them
in person and i want you and him to
do the best you can to make this really
grand
gestures wow this is so awesome big
hugs big music swells like the whole
thing right
and it can be funny cards and silly
cards and
a weird art project with hair and grass
whatever kids are up you know the
kids are doing stuff but i want them to
get a picture of what it looks like when
dad opens this or that
because then when they do these things
and they s and you mail them to them
or you have a weekly skype call with the
kids and your husband
overseas they're going to be able to
remember that and have a touch point to
it
right and so it's going to become part
of this rhythm that you can continue
when he's
overseas another thing you may want to
do is once a week have him
call them on on facetime on skype
they can get used to that conversation
that way of talking
and it can be silly and fun they can
come up with a game that they're gonna
do naturally
and then when he goes overseas and you
do a weekly
call with the kids and you get everybody
on then again they
they're able to have some touch point
feelings we remember that when dad was
inside and he was in the garage and now
he's overseas and this was pretty cool
and
it's not going to be easy it's going to
be fun and here's one last thing i would
recommend
see if your husband would be willing to
do
little bits of
pt with them little bits of training
little bits of hey we're gonna
dress up and so that they can have a
mental picture of what's dad's
day like when he's overseas is he
jogging and working out is he having to
do push-ups and sit-ups and the kids can
climb all over him
does he have to do jiu-jitsu practice
does he have to stand at a tension
really tall does he have to do some of
those things
and again all we're trying to do is to
connect pictures to their reality
right and then when he goes overseas
it's gonna be hard
yes they're gonna be so sad yes i'm
gonna be tears and hugs yes
but man they are not gonna have to
invent what his life looks like because
they'll have some pictures of what
that's gonna look like
and give them time to process this
um do you guys do things together y'all
have meals together
regularly uh breakfast and dinner we try
to
um really have together as a family i
love love that
so one thing that i would introduce and
you may already do this do you all do
some sort of
best and worst or the hardest laugh of
the day or your favorite thing of the
day
no we don't so start that tonight hey
new thing kids we're doing a new thing
at our house what's your bmws what's the
best thing
what's the worst thing that happened
what's the hardest thing what's the
funniest thing
and begin to introduce some of those
things so that when you're having a text
to your husband
the next morning if the kids have to go
to bed they don't get to see him or talk
to him or text with him
you could say hey i got dad's bmws from
last night again another touch point
so as you hear me saying that
does that sound doable or are you still
kind of freaked out that they're going
to know so far in advance
that that kind of puts it in a different
perspective
i know i love these ideas especially the
little pt training i think
the both kids would love love because
they always want to go to work with them
okay and so i think that one in the bmw
you know
it would it just would spark more
conversation between us
so you are a mom that had to hold it
together with a one and a three-year-old
i don't know how you did that that's
pretty impressive and you said our
marriage even your marriage even got
better
tell me what's going on in your heart
and mind during this transition
um nervous super super nervous
i'm currently i don't know i'm getting
emotional just maybe thinking about it
you're getting emotional because your
husband's about to go overseas that's
okay
um i'm currently full time in nursing
school as well okay
so i'll be in my last year and so just
trying to like balance it out making
sure the kids know
i'm present yeah even though i'm you
know my schedule's gonna be
crazy um
so kelly gave me a heads up before this
call
and i wanted to make sure i talked to
somebody who's got some actual
experience with this so i actually
called
my good buddy john who is a an active
navy seal and said hey what would you
recommend what would you and your wife
recommend because they've been through
this they've got kids
and the first thing you said you know
what he said was make sure
she has a gang
a group of people not even in the
military
sometimes that can be toxic right and
where everyone just talks and it kind of
gets gossipy it may be you may have a
great
circle of of military wives but i want
you to start cultivating
people that will be in your corner on
those hard days and those exhausting
days when
on final exam and midterm days on
rotation days
that they will be able to show up when
you text them and say hey can somebody
help with dinner and there will be no
questions asked they're just going to be
your ride or die for the next year
and if you take out a group of friends
you got a couple of friends like that
now
like just yeah i knew you would you
sound awesome
if you have those folks and you take
them out and say hey i'm starting to get
a little bit
because my husband's going to leave
again in a few months
i want to be able to count on you and
i'll pay for pizza and beer sometimes
but there's gonna be nights i text you
and call you and i want you guys i want
you to have this conversation over a
meal i want them to feel special
and i want you to let them know how
important they are to you and make it a
moment
and let them know what they mean to you
and then say there's gonna be nights and
i'm gonna call you
we just go pick up some kind of garbage
food for us to get us through the night
and they will be empowered and feel
awesome and feel good
and that's going to give them some
purpose somebody to support and love and
care on
while you're going through what you're
going through and
i know you did this last time don't
forget to
to stay in connection to communication
with your husband
always always i want to take a moment to
honor the service
men and women who go overseas and i
always want to take a moment and honor
the service men and women
spouses girlfriends boyfriends who are
staying at home raising kids
trying to get through school holding
down life
um that is a tough tough gig melinda i'm
so grateful for you thank you thank you
thank you for
your call thank you for your service let
me know how those conversations go with
your kids
and let us know how that works out it
will be a blessing and a gift to other
families in your same situation so
thanks for a call